there's a lot of debate in the
mainstream and social media on the
January 7th election particularly on the
percentage of turnout in the election
and the same thing is in the Bazaar in
the capital Dhaka we spoke to some of
the people here and this is a reaction I
I didn't go and vote because it wasn't
an inclusive election and the opposition
parties weren't there so there was no
point in a vote as it was already
decided everyone knows that this
election was not fair and legitimate we
thank the people for boycotting this
one-sided election and with the help of
the people we will continue our movement
and restore democracy to the
country prime minister Sheik H faces
major challenge in this new government
particularly in the economic sector she
has to deal with high inflation soaring
food prices and a very low Foreign
Exchange Reserve then the question of
international legitimacy so far the
Chinese and the Indian Envoy have
congratulated the Prime Minister but
what needs to be seen is how the
European Union and the United States
react to this election whether it will
give the legitimacy that the government
might be looking for cheni chadri Al
jazer
Dak make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer